fisherman on Myanmar's inland lake
performing their amazing balancing act
the technique is seen nowhere else in
the world nor is their unique method of
fishing both have been passed down
through the ages but recent years have
seen one dramatic change fewer fish
wootton win says water pollution in the
lake is to blame and the growing number
of fishermen an entire way of life for
people around the lake is under threat
but for a long time no one took any
action until now woot Edwin tune and his
colleagues are part of an initiative by
the United Nations they're coordinating
a program to save the lake and its
people the team is passionate about
their task le lake yeah is a one of our
historic place in our country so this is
my chance at to work here to save our la
that's why I'm very happy here
the first stop is an expanse of floating
fields anchored to the lake bed with
bamboo poles the dirt used to be packed
directly onto the pontoons but now the
farmers are growing their tomato plants
in plastic bags the idea came from
agricultural economist UMI's old he says
farmers are having to change generations
of practice but the results are worth it
but for laser into the better but that
valadares contained in the back no not
listen to the lake water it will prevent
the equalization of the lake water
locals are doing what they can to
support the program fishermen are now
organizing a no catch zone to allow the
dwindling fish stocks to recover
every few days they man observation
posts to make sure everyone is sticking
to the rules
you did do that whoa bhutan win says
he's proud to be part of the initiative
he's hoping the fish will be back soon
and that in future his son can carry on
in the lakes unique traditions
you